so naturally the biden administration is
calling for gun control understand this
is all part of their broader pitch which
is that joe biden needs to rule the
world this this
this man who is falling apart this
administration
that has 50 plus kamala harris in the
senate
is going to try to ram everything they
possibly can through axios is reporting
that now joe biden you know captain
propriety you know
the lion of the senate this long time
institutionalist
he's now looking at nuking the
filibuster according to axios president
biden recently held an undisclosed
eastern session with historians that
included discussion of how big is too
big
how fast is too fast to jam through once
in a lifetime historic changes
to america four things are pushing biden
to jam through what could amount to a 5
trillion
plus overhaul of america and vast
changes to voting immigration and
inequality
one his full party control of congress
two his party activists egging him on
three
he has strong gathering economic wins at
his back and four he is popular
in the polls natural naturally
presidential historian michael buschloss
was a big government
hack told the axios that fdr and lbj may
be the closest to analogs
to joe biden people close to biden say
he's feeling bullish on what he can
accomplish he is fully prepared to
support dashing the senate filibuster
rule
to allow democrats to pass voting rights
and other trophy legislation
for his party one because he loves the
narrative that he is bigger and bolder
than obama it's making him happy the
obama administration is ticked about
this by the way
obama is unhappy at this because he
wants to be captain transformation but
it turns out that it is biden
the old man who is coming in and just
showing him up
mitch mcconnell says this will create
such a fisher between the parties that
it'll be
nuclear winter but that's that's
basically right by the way that is
really not the risk the risk is not that
nothing gets done in the senate the risk
is that a bunch of stuff gets done in
the senate and that state governors just
say we are not going to go along with
any of this
you want to exacerbate the country's
national divides you want to make sure
that red states just stop helping out
the federal government
you want to make sure that the country
starts to fracture at all of its
seams do exactly what joe biden is doing
right now and by the way do it on the
issue of gun control
if joe biden tries to nuke the
filibuster in order to cram down federal
gun control
in complete contravention of the
constitution of the united states
good luck if you think that citizens of
texas
or alabama or tennessee or florida are
going to sit still
and let the federal government tell them
what to do with their guns the federal
government's gonna have another thing
coming you want to exacerbate conflict
to the point of possible violence that
is the exact way to do it
see here's the thing that the left needs
to understand about gun ownership for
people who are not
of the far left in the united states it
is a fundamental right
in the united states to be able to
protect yourself including with guns
the reason to own guns is to stop people
from violating your fundamental rights
and the first sign that your fundamental
rights are about to be violated is when
someone comes to your door and demands
your guns
okay so this is a completely
self-defeating proposal nonetheless this
is exactly what biden is apparently
pushing forward and now he's talking
about nuking the filibuster in order to
do all of this stuff
so jen sackey announced yesterday that
biden is considering executive action
on guns she apparently said putting in
place common sense gun safety measures
has been a passion of the president
since he was in the senate by the way
common sense gun safety measures that is
a euphemism for
gun control measures that have no
evidentiary backing
right like the 1994 assault weapons ban
which studies demonstrate did nothing to
stop mass shootings or to decline the
rate of homicide in the united states
apparently according to gen zaki his his
position on the filibuster has not
changed as of yet but we are considering
a range of levers including working
through legislation including executive
action that has been under discussion
will continue to be
under discussion trebiden himself came
out and called for gun control yesterday
of course he did
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an hour
to take common sense steps that will
save the lives
in the future and to urge my colleagues
in the house and senate to act
we can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
in this country once again
i got that done when i was a senator it
passed it was law for the longest time
and it brought down these mass killings
we should do it again
no it did not bring down the mass
killings the evidence on that is scanty
to nil
okay and again watching this incoherent
president
try to push forward a massive gun grab
is pretty
impressive stuff now by the way the
first the first notion that you should
have that the government is about to
invade your rights is when they tell you
they're not about to invade your rights
when they assure you that they're not
about to come for your wallet they're
coming for your wallet and when they
assure you that they are not coming for
your gun
pretty good time to start buying rifles
from bravo company manufacturing
before the government tries to make it
illegal to do so
so when vice president kamala hara says
don't worry you know they keep saying
we're coming for your guns
yes because you keep saying you're
coming for our guns that would be why i
remember when hillary clinton said this
in 2016.
in the 2016 campaign she was like they
keep saying that i want to come forward
i don't want to come for your guns i
just want an australian gun buyback
program oh you mean the mandatory gun
buyback program in australia
where they came for the guns like that
here's kamala harris saying
you don't need to feel threatened all
we're going to do is you know massive
gun legislation
and i believe that it is possible it has
to be
possible that people agree
that these slaughters have to stop and
this is again
reject the false choice and stop pushing
it for sure stop pushing the false
choice
that this means everybody's trying to
come after your guns that is not what
we're talking about
then who's go and i love that they're
part of that yeah yeah yeah no but then
who's guns you coming after
who's got like whose whose guns that
should be the question not what kind of
guns
whose guns because what i've noticed is
that you are not targeting criminals
right now they want felons to vote but
they want you the law abiding citizen
not to be able to get a gun
this is the democratic agenda at this
point again the evidence that the 1994
assault weapons ban did a damn thing
is just not there according to the
foundation
for according to the foundation for
economic education
these studies demonstrate that there is
no evidence assault weapons ban reduced
the homicide rate between 1994 and 2004
the federal government banned the
manufacturer sale or transfers of
assault weapons in large capacity
magazines
a doj study found no evidence the ban
had any effect on gun violence and
stated it should be renewed
the ban that should it be renewed the
ban's effects on gun violence are likely
to be small at best and perhaps too
small for a liable measurement because
again
if you're going to look at the kinds of
guns that are most frequently used in
homicides they are not long guns
they are not rifles and they are
certainly not rifles that are used
in mass shootings the number of mass
shooting homicides involving assault
weapons between 2007 and 2017
that's a 10-year period was 253. the
number of total homicides in the united
states was 150
000 the number of gun homicides in that
period was a hundred and four thousand
253 mass shooting homicides involving
assault weapons happen during that
period
so your notion is that you're going to
take the 100 million
right there are 100 million long guns in
circulation in the united states and
that's what you're going to target
it doesn't even make any sense
again the the the notion that assault
weapons bans
somehow generated a a
an impact on the frequency of mass
shootings it's just not there
the the prior to the ban on average five
people were killed with assault weapons
in the mass shootings per year during
the ban
the number went down before postband at
road to 22 but mass shootings with
assault weapons didn't rise until 2012.
that was eight years after the ban
ended in the seven years after the ban
there was an average of four people
killed in mass shootings with assault
weapons every year so maybe it turns out
it's not the kind of weapon that is the
problem maybe it turns out
that it is a bunch of different factors
that are the problem
okay but they have to lie okay they have
to lie about how easy it is to get a gun
they have to lie about the threat of
mass shootings in american society
generally
they have to lie about the efficacy of
gun control generally because again if
you actually told the truth about the
efficacy of gun control you know where
you might be looking chicago
washington dc new york city l.a
and it turns out gun control there has
not been wildly successful
the only thing that is tamped down
homicide is heavy policing
it is precisely the opposite of the
policy proposals the left legs
okay so instead they just have to
maximize the the way that they talk
about the problem so you'll have chuck
schumer talking about the epidemic of
gun violence first of all gun violence
is not an epidemic
we actually have been through an
epidemic in the last year an epidemic is
defined
by the contagiousness and
transmissibility of something
gun violence is not transmissible it is
not an epidemic it is acts of individual
evil those can be tamped down by adding
more police force
to places that are high crime but the
the what democrats are basically trying
to say is that the gun infects you
the gun does not infect you it is a
piece of machinery it is a tool
but here's chuck schumer saying we're
going to address the quote unquote
epidemic of gun violence
republicans seem averse to even wanting
to talk about the epidemic of gun
violence
like the start of the covet epidemic
their strat strategy is to downplay
and hope the problem goes away this
democratic-led senate will be different
the senate is not going to hide we're
going to debate and
address the epidemics of gun violence in
this country
okay but here's the thing if you look at
the number of homicides in the united
states
over the past 30 40 years we've had an
unprecedented drop
in the murder rate an unprecedented drop
in the united states murder rate
since basically 1994.
and yet the idea is that we are now
experiencing this mass epidemic
of gun violence the national murder rate
in the united states according to the
death penalty information center the
national murder rate
in the united states in 1992 was
9.3 per 100 000
population okay it reached its highs in
about that period
it is really high in the in the late 70s
and then kind of stabilized
and then its modern high was 1991 9.8
murders per 100 000 residents
currently in about 2016 2017 the lowest
it hit was about 2014.
4.5 murder it went in half in half
okay but the idea is that now it's an
epidemic and
again it is not an epidemic that's not
how epidemics work
but it's all a power grab and so they
have to lie so senator
padilla he says in a majority of states
is
alex padilla democrat of california he
says in a majority of states it is
easier to obtain a gun than to vote this
is just an overt lie there is not a
single state in the united states where
it's easier to obtain a gun than to vote
i mean do these people know a damn thing
about how you obtain a gun
you actually have to go in to a
federally licensed firearms dealer
and then you have to show id and then
they have to run a federal background
check on you and if there's a backlog
you might have to wait a couple of days
while they actually run
the federal background check on you
that's at a minimum
okay when you go to register to vote you
show an id and you're registered to vote
and that's the end of it
here's alex's just overtly lying there
won't be a media matters fact check on
this guy
in 25 states voters must be registered
and have specific forms of
id in order to cast the ballot but those
same
states allow people to buy rifles
without permits
and require no background checks for
some sales
additionally in the majority of states
new voters are
able to obtain a rifle quicker
than they're able to cast their first
vote
it seems to me that we have our
priorities entirely backwards when it
comes
to this when we make it easier to buy a
gun
these geniuses let's put them in charge
of whether you can defend yourself
meanwhile dick durbin who once called
american soldiers akin to pol pot
dick durbin said loopholes make it
easier for felons and abusers to get
weapons
okay again the the
proof that these felons and abusers are
getting weapons because of quote unquote
loopholes
is extremely scanty very very scanty
doesn't matter don't need evidence you
just make assertions because assertions
are all the left cares about
here's dick durbin making the case there
are well-known gaps in the federal gun
background check system
the gun show loophole the internet
loophole and more
these gaps make it too easy for felons
abusers and mentally unstable people to
get their hands on guns
and harm others okay so first of all
there is no gun show loophole if you go
to a gun show they have to be a
federally licensed firearms dealer
they what is the so-called gun show
loophole is not gun shows
okay that's me conveying a gun to my son
in order for the government to prevent
that they would have to have
full-fledged gun registries for every
gun in the united states
which is something that no advocate of
individual liberty should be in favor of
but let's be real about this this is
basically in the end just an emotional
appeal
this is why you have victims of mass
shootings going on tv and saying that
the nra
is a terror organization and then every
member of the nra is apparently a
terrorist here's fred gutenberg who's an
anti-gun activist
he's a parkland dad saying this on msnbc
they are a terror organization that is
making us less safe you can't
make up these things i mean literally
six
days ago the nra achieved its goal
and they called it victory for colorado
that's what they called it and here we
are
ten people dead including a police
officer because of what they
believe was victory for colorado okay
except that colorado already oh stop it
colorado already has universal
background checks red flag laws the city
of boulder
for two years it only expired six days
ago which is what the nra was talking
about they had an assault weapons ban
they had all of those things in place
again the evidence doesn't matter it's
the emotional appeal
and why don't we just we'll wreck the
filibuster and ram through gun control
that's what julian castro is now saying
he's saying filibuster reform to ram
through gun control because the
democratic agenda is the only thing that
matters and if you don't have evidence
to back it you just say that people who
who oppose you don't care enough and
don't have sympathy for people who have
died in mass shootings
i actually think this is going to be
another indictment of the filibuster
uh how do you not call something
strongly bipartisan in this country
when almost 90 of americans support it
and yet mainly one political party
stands
completely against it it doesn't make
any sense
and this is one more example of why in
the least
we need significant filibuster reform
that makes it
possible for effective meaningful
legislation
like this to to actually get enacted
i mean this is i'm sorry these people
are so
it's so ignorant i mean unbelievably
ignorant alison cameron just asked this
morning on cnn quote
how onerous would it be to have a gun
shop owner just say by the way are you
hearing voices
do you think people are chasing you do
you think everybody is watching you it
would have weeded out possibly this guy
yes i'm sure that if you want to weed
out criminals all you have to do is ask
them
whether they're mentally ill that would
totally do it by the way you know what
gun shops have to do i know because i
just purchased a gun the other day
you know what gun shops have to do they
ask you about your recent mental illness
history
it's a thing they ask you on the forums
again evidence is unnecessary here all
that matters that they are
morally right and very emotional about
it and therefore you are bad if you
oppose their evidence-free agenda
which suggests that all the problems in
america are based on individual rights
and apparently on white supremacy or
whiteness or something
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content